ああ今日は取っドクター始めた
ネタかぶりですあのぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーコンビと寿司ラーメン君が最近
こちらを使っておりまして
まるで石すごいリアルのスプレーするとそれが石井になっちゃうスプレーってのがある
んですよ本当に申し訳ございません
m-頭ですねた株を売るとめちゃうまっつい
税 jコミと寿司ラーメン君がもうやってまして
この石一プ0 day j コンビが9月の5日
捩らメイクが9月の11日でもちょっと待って
俺のこれの購入日みてください9月の5日前に買えば
た栗じゃないですあの頃に使ったからに使ったかないつ買ったり
俺いつだったっけはいこれ私の購入0件ですけど8月の21日に配列されております
強い私にパクリではないでー
ただ本当に二人にはお詫び申し上げます
まあいっしょ回数だけでなんか雑貨もを下げないなとか思いつつの別にそうでもない
気持ちでやっていこうと思います石井成スレすごいんですよたとえばここに私の
macbook がありますこれも桜かけると一緒になるのかな
関係あいながーの星にだというか濡れた状態で砂浜拭いた後の macbook って
感じですねはいここで同期た端思いますって見てもらった通りあの macbook が
めちゃくちゃ石化したんですよ
もちろんでこのおいしいになるスプですごいねそんなものにかけてもそのものが一緒に
なってしまう
最強のスプレー
出て気化させるスプリ猫するのはこちらスライブでございますもーもー
柔らかい固形ではないんです液体でもない間違いなくイシっとはかけ離れてる逆の存在
それがスライムこの石化するイメージがねスライムに石化するスクでをかけるとどう
なるのか
今日は実験してみたいと思うレッツゴー
[音楽]
はいという気でまずスライドをつくっていこう
あれ
me
[音楽]
いやーやっぱプロだなぁ
完成ですね
[音楽]
の
手際の良さが強いはもう完璧にサーブですねも綺麗に完成しました
a 完璧な配分今日も絶好調です
i 時で早速 thrive 完成したので
早速医師になるスプレーかけて行きたいと思いますでもマジでどうなるか分かりません
一瞬にさせたいものと絶対に固まらないものをこのスタートが交わるとき何を着るのか
このそ
いきます
でもわっっこれ
[音楽]
ちょっとあのこのスプレーてで冊だめっぽいカストル殺しますこうこれは一体何が起き
ているんだ
なんか若干あまぼこっぽい直樹たんですけど別に特にそんな
う
すぐに何か起きてるわけじゃないちょっと混ぜてみます
うわなんか1位
なんか全然力がなくなった気がするちょっともっと老けてみます
えー何か版って言えばいいんだろう
鳴らすすごいことになってきたぞわかるかなんか
手芸
繊維みたいになってきているなんやなんやなんやなんかね山力が増えたのかな
硬くなった気がしますねそのせくれてみよう
ひゃーすごいすごいすごいアキラのて通話の日食われるシーンみたいなんだはなくすぐ
ほんと女メン感が出てきたら合致でき省へやはり若干の石化要素を受けついて
るってことか
手で持てる者だって
ノッチるっちゃ落ちるけど何かすごいことになってきたら色を生んだ
結構いいし透明感が無くなりましたねチョコミント見ててから離れなくなっちゃったん
砂がすげーた人になってくださいなにこれもう明らかにねなんか違うもっとかけます
白バイバイ
ヒドロ戸田からなんて言うんでしょうなんかね今までにない食感をスライムになります
よね
[音楽]
まあめっちゃきたねー名前めっちゃつかめるようになってきたなんか明らかにちょっと
滑稽に近づいたり今日しますねう s go
こんなことになるとは私は思いませんでした
はもうなんか靴からになってきたあんたら自分たちですライブという事を忘れてきた
ねー
はい
吊らベタベタになるんですけどもめっちゃ何か切れ目が見える
ちょうどいいただ何がすごいってから離れないんですよ
なんだろこの特殊な感じすごい危なかっ築き方が異常なんで買ったやんカッパだけど
夏休み
はいというわけで s live に石化スプレーをかけまくるとヘッド不安になる
ことが分かりました
すごいよねなんかはい
大変教材でございました
そうですね
[音楽]
voodoo